and Alex before we do anything else we
must all say a huge congratulations to
Liam new daddy you and Cheryl have a
baby just over two months ago said Neil
I'm not that old
yes and you were there at the birth be
there the birth definitely yes I was
there at the birth and it was it was am
it was the most amazing thing and then I
was left with bear after after she gave
birth and she fell asleep and then I'd
never changed happy before until I met
bear so I was like I can do this
so I spent the whole day doing the nappy
changing business now I was getting
along with it just fine it was going
great admin read on we struck a deal
early doors and then at five o'clock in
the morning a bear woke up and my niece
was like I all did our due this one so I
was that cool you know fake bear his
first nappy change she brought in Ron
bales a nappy food first time it's
happened and then he starts sprouting up
we like a meeting like in my head was
music and slow-mo going on oh yeah it
was I think it was very ironic after she
did all the hard work I said we struck a
deal early door sue okay I think that
music and fluently was a life
[Music]
you